candace owen is the host of candace
she joins us now as we talk a little
biology and physiology can you make
sense of that rant
oh gosh isn't it so sad that we have to
talk about basic biology especially when
we're dealing with somebody who's a 32
year old congresswoman i'm sorry did i
say congresswoman i meant congress
menstruating person because apparently
we're no longer allowed to say women i
mean this is so ridiculous and here's
what's really funny she immediately
cripples her own argument here right her
argument is that the evil gop they're
taking away
actions that women were allowed to take
via abortion and but she's immediately
saying something worse forget the
actions women can take are we even
allowed to exist anymore this is what
her side represents it is so radical to
not even be able to formulate the word
woman because you feel too scared
because you need to accommodate all of
these various genders and trans people
are also women and this is also women
know women are women if you cannot enter
a debate about abortion and even
identify what it means to be a woman you
have no place in that debate
so you look at this texas law and she
immediately says
of course doesn't want to commit to a
gender but also says pack the court blow
up the filibuster does she have a
constituency candace is she an army of
one with a big profile does she speak
for a lot of people
in my personal opinion i've said this i
actually think aoc is very good for the
republican party she's very good for
conservatives i think she shows people
just how radical the left has become in
fact there was never this much
conversation about how radical left is
until she entered in and she said i'm a
socialist she started stomping around
and so people may not like her platform
but i think it is for the better you
know when she does something like shoot
today and she says oh the patriarchy and
patriarchal ideas and all the stuff that
they're saying and they're reducing us
to a uterus while at the same time not
recognizing that she is reducing women
to the idea that we're just menstruating
persons which is way worse i'd rather be
a uterus than be referred to as a
menstruating person you know it's good
for our side people need to see this
people need to see how just how radical
the left has become so candace we're
just getting this in now larry elder is
the leader if uh if they're going to
recall gavin newsom he'll be the next
governor he's leading the republican
side and evidently he just had a major
confrontation in los angeles we're just
getting this tape in let's just watch it
together
i don't know if you have a monitor there
but there's a bunch of white people and
a woman in a monkey mass taking a swing
uh at the at uh his security and
throwing eggs at larry elder classy
yeah i i've seen this and it's
absolutely infuriating i know larry
elder he's a friend he's a mentor he's
on the board of the blexit foundation
which is my foundation and let me tell
you something right now if this is on
the other side if a white woman wearing
a monkey mask uh threw an egg at a black
democratic candidate this would be
wall-to-wall coverage and actually this
might actually constitute a hate crime
in los angeles we need to find out
exactly who this woman is she needs to
be arrested and she should be charges
need to be brought because this is
absolutely criminal and disgusting and
it might be racist i'm not sure why she
was wearing the monkey mask i have no
idea why she was wearing it but i'd like
to see more information about that right
very interesting they also called larry
sun some of his entourage son and keep
in mind too
this is somebody they're trying to label
the black face of white supremacy
which is ridiculous on its face in its
definition a guy grew up in south
central wants to fix the state that's
been broken by the most inadequate
governor outside the one we used to have
here in quite some time candace owens
thanks so much and by the way larry
elder's going to be on tomorrow night
thank you for having me you got it
meanwhile joe